when apple announced their new macbooks
we set out to make the best most
comprehensive coverage anywhere on the
internet and we absolutely succeeded and
while doing so we made some
groundbreaking discoveries that nobody
else mentioned or even tested and at the
end of the year we finished off strong
with the final comparison of 2021
and what i found in it really sealed the
deal and made me regret my choice of a
laptop the 14-inch macbook pro with a 2
terabyte ssd 64 gigs of ram and an m1
max processor and in this video i will
tell you exactly why now i know that we
made an utterly insane amount of videos
on these machines so much so that i
myself am sick of them but you have to
admit these videos have and will help
hundreds of thousands of people answer
each and every question that they have
and save money many of them up to a
thousand dollars or more so it was well
worth the effort and for those of you
guys who haven't watched the latest ones
i want to share with you our latest and
final discoveries on the 14-inch macbook
pros and why these are so limited
compared to the 16-inch models despite
apple's marketing i have to start out by
making it very clear that the 14-inch
macbook pros are incredible pieces of
tech when compared to windows machines
and similar form factors as well as the
previous 13-inch macbook pros so if
you're set on this size i don't think
there is any other laptop out there that
offers this mix of features performance
and quality in this form factor no
matter how much money you spend i know
many people who purchase 13-inch macbook
pros over the years despite the
performance being much weaker than the
15 and later on the 16 inch macbooks
just because they love the form factor
in some cases they were their mobile
machines they would come back to a full
desktop and for others they would
connect an egpu to their macbook and
that would become their desktop with
more performance but as you guys know
the apple silicon chips don't support
external graphics cards so buying one
with the right performance matters more
now than ever before and for the first
time ever you can buy the same exact
specifications in a 14 inch macbook as
you can in a 16 inch model all the way
up to 8 terabytes of ssd which used to
be capped at 2 terabytes and 64
gigabytes of unified memory along with
32 graphics cores and an m1 max
processor now i've always been somebody
that loved the smaller macbook pros but
i had to buy the larger models because i
needed the extra cpu cores and the
dedicated graphics but finally in 2021 i
broke that cycle when i decided to
finally ditch the large macbook pro and
go with the 14-inch model a part of that
was the fact that i could get the same
configuration but the bigger thing was
just how large and heavy the big macbook
pros have gotten when apple moved from
the 15-inch model that i really liked to
the 16-inch it got longer wider and
slightly thicker along with almost 10
percent heavier but this year with this
redesign it grew even more than the last
time they changed it and let me tell you
it was significant so much so that it
sealed the deal with me going with a 14
inch macbook pro even though i figured
that it would be slower because of
thermals and i knew that it had worse
battery life i just kept picking this
one up and wanting to use it instead of
the 16 inch model especially when i was
going somewhere well now that it's been
two months and i have used and traveled
with the 14 inch macbook pro and i have
done way more testing and getting
comparisons against other configurations
do i regret buying this 14 inch 4100
macbook pro well like i said earlier
yeah a bit now especially because of my
most recent discovery that absolutely
shocked me ever since our first 14 and
16 inch comparisons we knew just how
huge of a difference there was in the
cooling systems of the smaller and
larger new macbooks the difference is
massive when you put them side by side
the fans look like they are almost twice
the size on the 16 inch and the same
thing goes for the heat pipes and the
fins where the hot air is exhausted this
of course makes sense since the 16 inch
is a lot larger thicker and about 40
percent heavier as well so if you think
about it is actually very impressive
that apple managed or decided to allow
such powerful chips like the m1 max to
be available in the 14 inch model but if
you've been following us for at least a
few years you will know that there is
such a thing as going too far where a
more expensive faster chip will actually
run slower than a cheaper and slower
chip because of thermal throttling now
on the inside we also found that the 14
inch has much smaller speakers in the 16
inch where at apple's event they said
that you get the same exact shockingly
good speaker system in both well i guess
you technically kind of do since both of
them now have six speakers with
dedicated warfares but after using them
side by side i can easily say that the
16-inch system is clearly far better
than the 14 inch with that said the 14
inch beats out most if not all 15 and 16
inch windows laptops and sound quality
but the 16 inch has such deep bass that
i'm still routinely surprised by just
how crazy it sounds with that low bass
that is kind of unbelievable that it's
coming from a laptop it takes movie
watching and music listening to a whole
another level that was impossible before
so after using it and then using my inch
i just know how much better the sound
quality is and what i am missing and it
makes me wish that i decided to lug
around the larger model now before i get
deep into performance i want to talk
about travel we recently went on a trip
and i took my 4100 14 inch maca pro
along with me the size was amazing since
it fits in any backpack or messenger bag
and it fit perfectly on the airplane's
tray table when i was doing some video
editing i have to be honest and say that
i'm really glad that i didn't have a 16
inch laptop it is just too large
especially if the person in front of you
decides to lean back causing you to have
to change the angle of the screen to
something that is almost unusable which
i've had that happened in the past with
my previous 16 inch that was actually
smaller than the current new model the
14 inch is the perfect size for those of
you guys that travel and also need good
performance now as far as battery life
on the other hand well it wasn't great
since i was pushing the machine pretty
hard doing video editing the battery was
draining fairly fast noticeably quicker
than any 13-inch macbook pro macbook air
that i've used to travel in the past now
as you guys know we have done some
battery life comparisons between
different configurations and there is a
startling difference and i want to give
you guys the latest update i use the
same test as luke miani which is using
gfx bench to push the systems pretty
hard simulating really real world tough
testing while at the same time being
able to keep it consistent so we can
actually compare instead of actually
just sitting there doing video editing
which can give you varied results after
just 45 minutes my 32 core 14 inch
dropped down to 52 battery life 12 lower
than the 24 core model while not
actually having that much more
performance due to thermal throttling
now the 24 core scales well in terms
performance from going from a 16 inch
but it only drops about 8 battery which
is quite interesting how well optimized
that model is of course it also runs
hotter since its fans have to work
harder to cool it down which also drains
more battery whereas the 16 core model
runs cooler and has much better battery
but of course less performance so tasks
can take longer jumping to the 16 inch
macbooks with the same test the 32 core
had 64 battery left so 12 more than the
14 inch but what that doesn't show you
is the fact that the 16 inch is much
more powerful as well being about 30
percent faster in tough gpu tests which
is a huge performance increase and even
though it uses more power and it runs
the gpu at the full 1300 megahertz
instead of about a thousand megahertz or
so for this task or even lower if it's
thermal throttling more the battery life
is still much better now of course you
can hook up a nice portable battery pack
to juice up your 14 inch and supplement
its battery that is about 40 percent
smaller than the 16 inch and that is
exactly what i did on the airplane in
regular daily use one thing you can't do
is get the extra performance difference
back i know some of you guys told me to
manually preset the fans higher to cool
down the 14 inch and i did try that but
it really doesn't make any difference
the system still heats up just as fast
and for the brief time that it runs cool
apple still artificially limits the
graphics to a maximum of 1100 megahertz
instead of the full 1300 megahertz on
the 16 inch what really got me though is
when i did my ultimate gpu comparison
and i pushed the machines hard in the
2500 base 16-inch macbook pro performed
practically the same as my 4100
14-inch that has double the graphics
cores and four times the memory um and
not only that that 16 inch model also
ran much cooler and almost silent
whereas this 14 inch was blasting its
fans at full blast this really sealed
the deal for me just knowing that my
expensive 14-inch macbook pro is the
worst value new macbook pro that is out
there now i knew that it would thermal
throttle and it would have worse battery
but not by this much and after a few
months of testing it and using it
knowing just how much better the 16-inch
macbook pros are it is really a bummer
the apple's 14-inch is limited both
thermally because it's smaller as well
as artificially because apple is locking
down the graphics performance even if
you're plugged into power
and your system is running cool it is
crazy that the 16 inch base model can
even outperform it in some tough cases
i really think that apple should give
this 14 inch the high power mode that
the 16 inch macbook pro has because it
is actually useful for this machine
allowing it to reach its full
performance if your battery is good and
the system isn't already preheated up
and running really hot in thermal
throttling now at this point while i
really like the 14 inch form factor i'm
going to try to get over that
extra size and weight just because i
know how much of a better value the 16
inch model is costing just 200 more but
giving you more value better thermals
quieter fans better performance overall
and way better battery life as well and
you can actually save money and get a
weaker spec
but overall have better performance than
using a 14-inch machine so overall do i
regret getting this expensive 14-inch i
think so and i think if i got maybe the
24 core even more of the base model it
provides a way better value and a much
more optimized system as far as the
performance in the form factor compared
to this 32 core m1 max you guys let me
know your opinions if you're somebody
that bought a max out 14 inch what is
your experience been like and did you
expect it to be slower than a much
cheaper 16 inch i just want to get all
that latest info out there for you guys
that didn't watch the latest comparisons
it really is a shocker and some stuff
that nobody really talks about or even
tested so i'm glad that we could do that
for you guys go ahead and click that
circle above to subscribe and help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
we would greatly appreciate it and check
out one of those great videos right over
there this has been max and i will see
you in the next video
[Music]